Devil fruits have a will of their own that
can be inherited through the generations,
which is exactly why the Gomu Gomu no Mi is
so important.
Now same as me, you probably have been very
focused on Haki for the past couple of years,
which just makes sense.
This may sound harsh, but Devil fruits simply
were not that interesting for a while.
Until Doflamingo revealed the next level:
Awakening.
And, minor spoiler, since this topic has become
relevant again in recent chapters with the
revealed awakenings of Kid and Law, I couldn't
help but wonder: Has Luffy awakened his Devil
Fruit as well?
And what would it actually look like?
And most importantly, what is the secret behind
them?
For the first time in a while that really
got me thinking.
To the point where I was lying in bed at night,
unable to sleep.
My analytical brain shifting into overtime
gear, told me that there had to be some clues
in the story.
I just HAD to find out what the true nature
of devil fruits truly was.
So what did I do?
Well, what any reasonable person would do
at 4am in the morning, I got up, opened my
laptop and started working.
I was gonna analyze every type of fruit, every
type of fruit and every instance of awakening
until a few hours later, I actually completed
this crazy puzzle of clues, that connects
Luffy, Roger and Joy Boy.
But I'm getting ahead of myself here.
Hi my name is Manu, my favorite fruit is pineapple,
and in this video I will pull back the curtain
for you on the true nature of devil fruits.
Because the devil truly lies in the details
here.
The first thing I did, as I usually do with
any theoretical analysis, was to establish
the facts.
What do we actually know.
And even though you're probably already familiar
with this, it's gonna be critical for the
juicy bit later on and let's be real, there
are definitely less fun things than learning
some facts about devil fruits.
Okay, so baseline is: these fruits seem to
have been around for a long time and have
become a regular part of the one piece world.
While they are considered quite rare and special,
on the grand line, that attracts only the
strongest and weirdest people, they are found
on a much more common basis.
As Shanks explains, it is said that these
powers are all incarnation of a sea devil.
And if you try to eat more than 1 fruit, the
two devils will start fighting, resulting
in the death of the user.
There are 3 types of devil fruits, each with
their own subcategories.
Pineapple, Banana and orange.
Just checking if you're still paying attention.
Zoan fruits allow their users to transform
into an animal, giving them access to their
regular form, their animal form as well as
a hybrid form.
Subcategories include ancient Zoans for animals
that have gone extinct like dinosaurs, mythical
Zoans that include mythical creatures like
the phoenix as well as a separation in herbivore
and carnivore types, boosting endurance and
defense or speed and offense respectively.
[chopper about lucci]
Next are Logia fruits.
They are pretty easy to summarize.
As you know, a logia turns the body of its
user into an element, for example fire.
Regular physical attacks are useless here.
And this.
Is little known, but Logia users actually
can enhance their powers significantly by
subscribing to my channel for next generation
anime content.
Paramecia fruits then are the dumping place
for all powers that don't fit in the other
two categories.
There are a lot of subcategories here.
Some users can enhance their bodies.
Luffy's enhancement is permanent.
He's a rubber man.
Mr. 1 for instance can transform his body
at will, while someone like brook only gets
the effect of his fruit through a certain
event, in this case death.
Other users are able to produce a power.
Some can produce materials, like Doflamingo's
string, others can produce a force of nature,
like Whitebeard, while again others can produce
entire worlds of their own, such as Mon't
D'or or Brulee.
Lastly, there are people who I guess basically
do magic.
There is people like Sugar who can manipulate
living things, people who have control over
a certain space, like Law or Corazon and some
even crazier powers like Big Mom's soul manipulation.
In general, there are 4 known weaknesses to
devil fruit powers.
First and maybe most dangerous, is losing
the ability to swim.
If a user is submerged into water, they are
drained of all energy and incapable of moving
or using their powers.
Which in a world of pirates consisting to
99% of water is a pretty damn big handicap.
Simply throwing a glass of water at them won't
work though - probably.
The next best thing though is sea prism stone,
which is mined in Wano and comes with its
own set of mystery of how its made and why
it works.
The end result however is that this material
has the same essence of the ocean.
Which is why it can be used to take out an
ability user even on land and without throwing
that glass of water at them.
Third is Haki.
More specifically armament haki or as it's
called in French: Haki de l'Armement.
Mon dieu.
This can be used to forcibly turn a devil
fruit users body back into regular flesh and
bones, no matter how it was transformed or
shaped.
And I never really thought about it for some
reason, but isn't it really strange that Haki
has this effect devil fruits?
Well small tease here: This is gonna be one
of the details in which the devil will be
found later.
Better put on some pants devil!
Lastly, and this will also play a role, there
is one devil fruit power out there that has
the ability to absorb and nullify any other
power: Blackbeard's Yami-Yami no mi, that
he calls the strongest logia out there.
Finally, the most rescent thing we learned
is that devil fruits can be awakened.
Basically, by mastering one's ability and
being able to fully control it at will, the
user starts to unlock a new level of his fruit,
that in some way or form enhances its power
and or reach.
Zoan users generally get access to a giant,
monster-like hybrid form that boosts all their
physical attributes and also let's them recover
very fast form even the most fatal attacks.
Examples for this are the guards in impel
down, as well as most likely chopper's monster
point.
While we haven't seen a logia user officially
awaken, it is pretty safe to assume that such
a power permanently changes the environment
around them.
This is not only based on Doflamingo's explanation,
but also on how the landscape of punk hazard
was permanently changed after the battle between
Aokiji and Akainu, as well as Raijin island,
that suspiciously looks like someone went
a bit cray cray with Enel's fruit there.
Lastly, we have the wide range of paramecia
users.
While producers like Dofi, Kid and Katakuri
are able to change their environment as well
as their body in their awakened state, someone
like law seems to get additional abilities
for his fruit, like creating shockwaves inside
the body.
And actually, I think there is a pretty good
chance that Luffy's awakening is already here.
If you want me to talk about that as well,
let me know.
So now that I had established all that we
knew about devil fruits and consumed 2 cups
of coffee, it was time to go clue hunting.
Okay, so there are a couple of things that
got me wondering about the true nature of
devil fruits and if there wasn't more to all
of this.
Without making it unnecessarily dramatic,
I was wondering whether devil fruits were
in some weird way alive.
While the talk of the sea devil residing in
the fruit might have seemed like casual sailor
talk in early one piece, shanks turned out
to be one of the most well-informed and powerful
people in the story, and I have already talked
about in other videos how Shanks most likely
was not simply chilling around in the east
blue, but actively following Rogers orders
to find the man he was waiting for.
So my thesis statement is gonna be that this
explanation by shanks to buggy on board of
roger's ship is literal.
There resides a devil inside every fruit,
that is then transferred into the body of
the person that consumes it and merges with
their soul.
Let me try and proof it to you.
By the way shoutout to all the people online
who have thought about this as well.
I think I read through at least 20 blog posts
on this topic.
First of all we have the incarnation of devil
fruit powers.
When a fruit user dies, his ability is shown
to leave the body, like a soul, and travel
to the nearest fruit of the same type.
For example, smiley's zoan-type fruit would
always be an apple, which is why there can
be a devil fruit encyclopedia in the first
place, that Blackbeard used to identify the
Yami-Yami no mi.
The soul leaves the host and finds it's next
container.
Once someone takes a bite of this new fruit,
the devil enters the body and the rest of
the fruit is useless.
Except for vitamins, which are important.
Basically, your soul and the soul of the devil
merge.
On Enies Lobby, Jabra explains to us that
two devils would fight if you tried to consume
a second fruit, killing the user in the process.
The biggest evidence that devil fruits have
a will of their own however are Funkfreed,
Smiley and the second best dog in one piece,
Lassoo.
All three of them are objects, a sword, a
gas weapon and a gun that have gained consciousness,
free will and the ability to turn into an
animal.
The only explanation, is that the soul contained
in the devil fruit is transferred into the
object.
Pretty much the successful version of what
Caesar tried to do with the smiles.
These objects now understand human speech
and even have a will of their own, as is shown
in this scene here.
[]
And if their own will, that also gives us
an answer as to why devil fruits have their
respective weaknesses.
If the sea devil grants these powers, he would
take them back, once you sink into him.
His will is stronger than yours and that of
your smaller devil.
Similarly, Haki is able to overcome a fruit,
not because it overcomes the haki of the owner,
but of the devil fruit itself.
Otherwise, every-time someone tried to use
haki on another user, they would be stuck
in limbo fighting it out for a while before
they could actually forcibly change their
bodies back.
As for Blackbeard: If his devil fruit truly
is the strongest devil fruit, and I have to
admit the darkness fruit seems like the most
devilish one there is, that would mean that
the devil in his fruit is stronger than any
other devil, and that it nullifies their abilities
in the same way.
Awakening your devil fruit then could be a
quite literal phrase.
When you are under water your devil is asleep.
In your everyday state, the devil is in something
of a dream-state, sharing their abilities.
But when you awaken, the full potential of
the fruit is unleashed.
Wish the awakening, the devil part of your
soul would of course become stronger, which
is exactly what we see in the prison guards
in impel down.
They are more animal than human, just as with
chopper, who has to train hard to get control
over this state.
People like Doflamingo and Katakuri clearly
have control over it, but nonetheless all
the awakened fruits we know cause are incredibly
destructive to their surroundings and are
hard to keep in check.
And they also require an enormous amount of
energy.
You literally are fighting with the devil
over control.
Seeing how kid and law struggle with it, conqueror's
haki might well be an advantage in dealing
with this state.
Doflamingo and Katakuri after all, both were
able to use their awakening quite creatively
and bend the rules of their normal powers.
But what comes next is what you probably have
been waiting for and it will hopefully really
blow your mind.
When I realized it I definitely could see
a light turning on above my head.
It felt like Luffy was watching over me, thanks
to the awesome sponsor of today's video: The
awesome people over at Weeblamp, who sent
me these fantastic custom anime lights.
Each of them can be illuminated in 16 different
colors and 4 different modes and I like to
dim mine down a little for that ambient feel.
The look really nice on my shelf and are actually
the perfect addition to the video background
I'm trying to build here.
Not only do they have tons of great options
on their website already, but you can even
custom order your own lamp from whatever anime
or manga you want.
And kindly enough, they were even willing
to give you guys a 15% discount when using
the code Ohara at checkout.
Okay, I'm gonna tell you, that the devils
soul not only merges with your own, it also
takes on some of your properties.
In other words, devil fruits are used to inherit
someones will.
Let me guide you through this.
The best example case is Ace and his mera
mera no mi.
Sabo mentions that they have to get his fruit
back so they can inherit that persons will.
Similarly, Blackbeard, who tried recruiting
Ace into his crew before capturing him, tells
Luffy that burges will take the fruit and
it will be as if ace joined himself.
However, it could just be that they are talking
about his legacy.
But, when Sabo eats the fruit and blows away
Burgess, he says this really strange line:
[]
And even more strangely, I found that Sabo
started acting like Ace- Even the way he says
goodbye, was the same as ace did on Alabasta.
[] And just a bit later, Sabo goes off on
his own at Marijoe and potentially gets captured,
just like ace.
But, you might rightfully say, that might
just be because him and ace were really close.
Well here is exhibit number 2.
Big Mom and Mother Caramel.
We know for a fact that Linlin was an extremely
kind and caring kid, that at times lost control
trying to do good things.
However, after consuming mother caramel-'s
fruit, caugh, she started turning evil and
took on many of caramel's traits.
She starts calling herself big mom, has the
same devilish smile and lipstick and while
mother caramel was using orphans for her benefit,
Big Mom uses her own children for hers.
The same is true for the weapons that consumed
fruits.
They take on certain personalities.
And a really interesting example is actually
Kalifa.
She was introduced as this incredibly serious
woman.
But once she ate her devil fruit she started
doing things like this: []
Similarly Blackbeard suddenly wants to be
called admiral after eating his fruit.
Two other interesting people in this category
are Bartolomeo and Mr 2.
Both of them as we know are very kind and
caring people at heart, but while Mr. 2 joined
Crocodiles dark organization to take down
a country, Bartolomeo is known to be very
cruel to those outside the straw hats.
Did you ever find that strange?
Well, now that we know that both of these
fruits belonged to the Kurozumi clan, and
they inherited their cruel and scheming ways,
that would make sense.
But the real mind-blow to me was applying
this to Luffy.
For some strange reason, the gomu gomu no
mi has turned out to be way more important
than we actually thought.
It was stolen and protected by shanks, who
got into a conflict with the world government
about it.
Now, I have always hated the idea that Roger
had ate the Gomu Gomu no mi as well.
But looking at it though this lense, what
if he had and Luffy took on some of Roger's
personality traits?
So many characters draw parallels between
Luffy and Roger, down to Luffy saying the
exact same things as the first pirate king.
Luffy's reaction at his execution in Logue
town: Roger.
Luffy's reason to look for the one piece:
Roger.
And its only after Luffy eats the gomu gomu
no mi that he declares his dream to become
pirate king for the first time to shanks,
upon which he gives him roger's old hat.
Now, if this were true shouldn't we already
know that Roger had the same fruit as luffy?
That should be common knowledge after all.
But what if this was actually joy boy's fruit?
Now this is admittedly speculation, but what
if Roger found this fruit on Laugh tale, consumed
it, inherited Joy Boy's will and died a little
later without most people ever knowing?
For his execution, as we know, knives still
work on Luffy.
Wouldn't it make a lot of sense if this was
the true reason this fruit was special?
Not because it has some secret rubber power,
but because it has Joy Boy's and Roger's inherited
will in it?
And remember Roger's last words to Rayleigh.
[] He literally remembers them after meeting
Luffy.
Now this theory is based on a lot of analysis,
but if you want something even bigger, I suggest
you check out the best one piece theory ever,
right here.